lo scopro niente ed a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo modo sono fa vj ed
oggi siamo su di introd ai videogame che
consiste nello scappare da un intruso e
dato che mi ha anche sfilato il telefono
non è una cosa tanto normale però
proviamoci lo stesso allora siamo al
governo
john è pronto di audi steel rain in
north bergen said that cedeva la prima
devo entrare in casa perché sta piovendo
se ovviamente c'è un intruso prendete mi
hanno chiamato dicendo che c'è un
intruso bene che sembra non esserci
all'interno puoi vedere la porta
leggermente socchiuso ragazzi entriamo
non vedo l'ora
voglia che cos'è chi è questo babbo
natale l'intruso sa che sei qui
nasconditi velocemente cosa devo fare
devo fare la secondi di nella prossima
stanza bene così che brutto che io sono
qui sono qua ciao sono un po vj piacere
anno mi ha visto bene così che abilita
direi di tornare indietro è abbastanza e
tante per essere un gioco in flash
comunque magari c'è un'altra strada
dalla quale poi entrare in casa perfetto
lega dobbiamo trovare un'altra strada
io me ne andrei in macchina di corsa
sinceramente però va bene non fa niente
andiamo in giardino ci sia parecchio
bagnato ed è meglio e trovare un rifugio
prima che la morte ti prenda troviamo un
rifugio per un amor di dio
magari c'è qualcosa all'interno si
perfetto troviamo un'ascia da piantare
in testa a quel pezzente una batteria
ragazzi una batteria tutti i nostri
problemi sono fottutamente risolte c'è
un casino di roba inutile ma magari c'è
qualcosa che vale la pena portarsi una
scatola ragazzina un'altra batteria bene
così
raga io non so che cazzo clicco
qualsiasi cosa bene cos'è questo
la chiave la chiave la chiami le giacche
millesi in testa la spina alla corrente
gliene il filo nel culo a mora che ha
due batterie adesso sono effettivamente
pronto a combattere andiamo così devo
riuscire a trovare l'entrata sul retro
dovrebbe essere questa credo se grandi
continua per il retro vai così ragazzi
stiamo per entrare tenetevi pronti
questa torcia prendi aprendo perfetto
ragazzi adesso vado come lo slang sembra
un posto sicuro per entrare in casa
perfetto da entriamo siamo la porta
sorretto da bloccato ovviamente tutto
aperto in una casa giusto allora è la
cucina la lavanderia andiamo a prima
lavare e poi a mangiare cos'è chi è
quello ma allora sembra testa di minchia
ma che cazzo lo sai che sin qui in
ascolti velocemente questo fare
mi abbia tolto un gatto mi ha donato un
piatto che soluzione di merda basta come
gatto il mercato sta tornando indietro
cioè creduto mica come i miti gatti
ragazzi ma chi lo sa meglio di me
allora adesso che ci siamo salvati
fingendoci dei gatti perfetti mi fico in
lavatrice
si può fare torno indietro c'è attorno
perfetto ragazzi torniamo vediamo se ci
ha creduto nessuno
serve un coltello o più che altro devo
tornare in cucina se riecco la cucina
ragazzi la cucina ti prego fammi entrare
se si cucinano inizio né c'è un fatto
dov'è la nutella maledetti dove nel
freezer nel freezer ragazzini frisa alla
nutella
il calendario è stato marchiato perfetto
veloce però è il compleanno di sarah
tanti auguri a sarah che è probabilmente
già morta
halloween e vabbè compleanno di sarah
sai che cazzo me ne frega però non
importa quando si può fare una mazza
andiamo avanti introdotti dalle spalle
come si permette no kat
sono andato lì la vera mente un giorno
non volevo l'intruso nella prossima
stanza vuoi continuare no torna indietro
e torna indietro bene così e ancora lì
perfetto allora cosa è questa la
lavanderia e le fiamme la lavanderia
prima che succeda qualcosa di brutto
dalla mandria conduce la cantina
perfetto raga ho trovato la cantina c'è
una pistola per caso no vero non sia mai
che trova in arma maledizione è una
combinazione che cazzo ne so io
clicca per entrare a ragalna
combinazione quand'è che era il
compleanno della bambina di nuovo mi
ricordo devo andare a vedere il
compleanno della bambina di sicura e la
data di nascita
e anche se mi angolo meglio di te sono
cazzi tuoi niqab ea va beh siamo in
cucina ragazze può trovare potuto
calendario non mi coro questo sono
sicuro che è così e compleanno di sale
al 20 quindi siamo il 31 c halloween
quindi questo ottobre quindi 20 febbraio
marzo aprile maggio giugno e luglio
coste lampard o per di ex e quindi o
eventi 10 o e 10 20 dipende
dal jazz sono americani mettono il mese
prima del giorno va beh se è così
veramente mi faccio un monumento ok la
la combinazione incorretta forse così
non ci credo perché consoni genio mio
zio ma sherlock holmes mi fa due pippe
non una ma come cazzo fatto mio dio dove
la scala e valdisotto nell'oscurità
perfetto ragazzo noi [ __ ] haqyar del
secolo
cos'è clicca per riportare l'energia in
casa è che siamo in rosa che ci siamo
perfetto sono un po tutto genio si è
sparito raga non c'è più proseguiamo per
il corridoio vediamo dove dobbiamo ecco
qua dove mi hanno nascosto prima ma
andiamo avanti nel cuore di quanto cazzo
grande sta a casa e lì
l'intruso sta aspettando seguito nella
bile senza è una pesante armatura
continuato a rischio
torna indietro grandi così il coraggio
da leone all ufficio l'ufficio magari ce
l'hanno ancora in ufficio fusi disturbo
cercavo solo l'armatura cazzo il
messaggio chi è che mi sta chiamando
adesso mio dio virtuoso sta arrivando
rispondi veloce nascosti sotto la
scrivania scrivania
c'è un computer lodiamo su facebook che
devo controllare le notifiche bravo così
vediamo cos'è sta roba labirinto raga
cos'è
cosa può fare qui c'è una pallina che si
muove bello
devo arrivare alla fine senza toccare i
bordi
l'intervista
ok io non proverò mai questi giochi
nella vita reale per paura che mi spunti
qualcuno da dietro se perdo e mia
coltelli bene così
re che abbiamo soltanto una vita
edizione perfetto sono nella merda
il cellulare un nuovo messaggio perfetto
leggiamo suo messaggio ma se la al
cellulare di sarah
leggiamo i messaggi di sarà magari mi
stava tradendo stai bene mi sono chiusa
nella camera da letto
prendi la trama nell'ufficio la cassette
proteggiti ti amo pistoia di merda ma
quasi fatto uccidere che mi scrive ti
amano l'acqua ancoro è chiuso magari
puoi fare leva per aprirlo con che cosa
faccio leva perché le mine ultimamente
stanno funzionando il che è parecchio
strano tipo infatti lo sapevo finalmente
la pistola maledizione così facciamo il
culo come si deve però a ci sono i
proietti perfetto grance tutto c'è tutto
pistola proiettili click gun anytime e
familiare porca [ __ ] va bene un letto
comunque il mirino è na figata ragazzi
scott dillo che mi guardavi notifiche di
facebook bastardo
vabbè usciamo di qua come si esce non mi
ricordo dove forse questa micro doveva
si è perfetto ci siamo
raga ciò possiamo fare noi così bastardo
sono fottutamente morto
stavolta ti faccio un culo stronzo non
spara porca [ __ ] che cosa può premere
per sparare
questa cosa devo fare disarma immortale
cielo colpito però mio cosa è successo
mi ha colpito lo stesso anche se sei
stato colpito ma stai bene certo una
coltellata ma sto bene lì ritroso e
ferito ed è quasi morto con l'ultimo
sparo alla testa potrei farlo ci siamo
ragazzi giustizia mo sto stronzo
la stanza di sam qui è dove si sta
nascondendo tutto stronzo aiuto edizione
la caccia devo fare un'ultima [ __ ]
vita c'è da fare ma rilanciato fare
forum e joseph l'intruso è morto
perfetto c'è una chiave sembra la chiesa
nella chiave della stanza di di sarà
perfetto brutto bastardo prova a
metterti contro fa vj brutto stronzo
prova cc ma devo tornare devo liberare
sahara ma gli sparo pura sarà con la
[ __ ] di merda ma quasi fatto uccidere
mai così ci siamo la porta aperta giusta
stranka
sono io berna sono io sono insomma io
sono io sono io so che se i trojan
aperto sei spaventata dal terrore e
accecata dal panico non riconosce chi
sei parà lei per primo buttala giulio no
spara le mappe bastarda che il nuovo
ridotta stronza mi stavi per uccidere te
lo meriti e fini aridaje sto telefono ma
che cazzo successo non è morto come
cazzo né morto né sparato in testa forse
era la pistola che rabbia un vini non lo
so perché non è morto va bene ragazze
concluso più l'episodio semi dove è
piaciuto come al solito al santo
commetto mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come in ogni video tolta la
descrizione sensi per iscritti
iscrivetevi noi ci rivediamo il prossimo
vita beh ragazzi